un sommet entre vladimir poutine et joe
biden avec emmanuel macron comme
intermédiaire voilà ce sur quoi se sont
mis d'accord les états unis et la russie
selon l'elysée une rencontre qui ne
pourra se faire que si moscou n'envahit
pas l'ukraine et dont le contenu sera
préparé par le secrétaire d'état en tony
blinken
et le ministre des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov lors de leur rencontre du
24 février un entretien avec toutes les
parties prenantes devraient ensuite
avoir lieu plus tôt dans la journée
emmanuel macron c'est séparément
entretenu avec ses deux homologues
obtenant de la russie son engagement
d'intensifier les efforts diplomatiques
la france et la russie indique toutefois
avoir constaté des différences
d'interprétation quant aux raisons de l'
escalade dans la région de donbass ou
plusieurs centaines de tirs de mortier
et d'artillerie ont été recensés moscou
accuse les ukrainiens paris les
séparatistes pro-russes l'annnonce du
maintien de 30000 soldats russes en
biélorussie après la fin de leur
exercice dans le pays a également été
évoquée
vladimir poutine a affirmé son intention
de retirer ses troupes sans pour autant
préciser la date les etats unis
continuent de marteler que la russie est
sur le point d'envahir le cren tout en
justifiant l'absence de sanction au
profite efforts diplomatiques
nous continuons de faire tout ce que
nous pouvons pour dissuader poutine de
suivre le cap sur lequel il s'est engagé
jusqu'à la dernière minute il ira
toujours une option pour la faire faire
machine arrière on essaie d'empêcher une
guerre dès que vous déclenchez des
sanctions l'art effet dissuasif
disparaît elles sont absorbées par le
président poutine ou saint lô fce dont
la pologne assure la présidence
tournante organise ce lundi une réunion
extraordinaire pour discuter de la
rapide détérioration de la situation
sécuritaire sur le terrain